good evening the question tonight can
you get copied
after you're vaccinated the answer yes
but it's extremely rare
thanks for joining us here at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis those
covet cases are known as
breakthrough cases and researchers do
want to know a bit more
orc omana joins us live with those
breakthrough cases
well brian and denise we need to make
sure first of all that we're talking
about the people
who contracted coven 19 more than two
weeks
after their second dose which is when
they're supposed to be fully immunized
but experts tell me
that breakthrough coveted cases can
still happen after that
and those results that can result in
cases that are pretty mild
well the vaccine doesn't make you
bulletproof as more people across the
country become fully vaccinated a small
number of them
still contract covid19 these are known
as breakthrough cases
we saw these in the clinical trials
infectious disease epidemiologist brian
labis tells me he's not surprised after
all
both pfizer and modernist said their
vaccines were around 95 percent
effective
not a hundred percent breakthrough cases
are also extremely rare a new study
shows that out of roughly 8 100
vaccinated employees at a texas medical
center only four became infected
and labis says the symptoms are not
severe all the vaccines we have are
excellent at preventing hospitalization
and death so even if you do get infected
it's going to be the mild disease the
southern nevada health district tells me
it has no reported breakthrough cases
but officials in minnesota have seen
89 while experts say we should not be
too concerned more research
is needed what's common in the people
that appeared to get sick
after vaccination did they all receive
the same batch of vaccine did they all
get vaccinated
at the same site as those questions are
answered vaccinated nevadans are urged
to keep wearing masks and social
distancing in public
we still need to take those steps to
protect ourselves and our friends and
family from this disease
i also reached out to the governor's
covet 19 response team to see
if breakthrough cases have been reported
anywhere else in nevada
they have not gotten back to me yet but
again experts want to stress that the
effectiveness of the vaccine is still
very high
reporting live tonight orca mana 8 news
now